and if you know anybody coming to town
tell them to bring an extra jacket
because i've had friends want to borrow
some before new year's eve tens of
thousands of people go i thought it was
always 100 degrees in las vegas man what
are you doing
it gets downright cold here we're going
to talk about freezing temperatures or
near freezing when we welcome in the new
year here we start with a live picture
from our camera on top of the bank of
america building this is uh up at
rainbow in the 95. the flag moving
around a little bit you can see the
strat there of course it'll be a great
view for the fireworks set to happen on
friday night the official temperature 34
degrees but neighborhoods we are a
little bit cooler you're at the freezing
mark now for summerlin aliante 28 at the
air force base 29 sunrise mountain below
freezing out at the lake so
taking a walk walking the dog as heather
mentioned maybe not a hundred layers but
you definitely want to layer up let's
check nevada and beyond the snow as you
know has been dumping up in the reno
area tonopah you're at 26 same with baby
ely at 16. the winter storm warning
means a lot more snow for caliente the
mountains outside of cedar city and it's
going to be upwards of a foot of new
snow for lee canyon over the hump and
prop you're at 30 29 for sandy valley
now this future cast tells you kind of
what you need to know it is not going to
be raining anytime soon yesterday we
called it the in between day by 10
o'clock this morning still just a couple
of clouds even by two o'clock maybe the
snow starting up in lincoln county and
over the spring mountains by five
o'clock possibly some sprinkles here
that may be about it until later tonight
we're talking about a total of a quarter
of an inch accumulation so by nine
o'clock it really will start moving on
in here yesterday we made it to 49 we
think that's what we'll do today there's
the normal high of 56. some
neighborhoods already at the freezing
mark the high country snow dumps
continue and that is the case across the
eastern great lakes
record warm temperatures so this is a
lot of rain it's 16 below zero right now
in bismarck but this is the right now
temperature for new orleans and houston
at 72 when those two air masses get
together it's not going to be pretty to
welcome new year
okay so 49 today we'll try for 50 late
tonight off and on all day tomorrow
tapering off in the last day of the year
but cold temperatures as we get you into
2022